hey everyone I'm Kate and this is your
gamespot news update now you might have
thought the whole Kajima konami
conspiracy theory peaked at the head
transplant story a few months ago but
now it's still going strong with Konami
themselves now denying that Cod even
left at all after they took his name off
all the games and held an actual goodbye
party those were just coincidences and
kajima is fine oh look is that him over
there oh you just missed him it was
right now konami has responded to a
detailed report which revealed that
Metal Gear creator Hideo Kojima has left
the company the publisher suggests that
he is still an employee and on a lengthy
vacation following the protracted
development of metal gear solid 5
according to Japanese publication Tokyo
sports which has been translated by
Kotaku a Konami spokesperson said
currently kajima is listed as a company
employee and went on to say the extended
Lee was normal for console game
development projects currently Kajima
and the development team have finished
developing metal gear solid 5 and are
taking a long time off from work the
representative said because the
development time for console games is so
long and fatigue builds up it's common
for employees to take extended periods
of time off when development is finished
the publisher did not say whether or not
Kojima had secured a new contract at the
company nor whether it wanted to
maintain the 29 year partnership on
Monday it was reported that Kajima
parted ways with Konami earlier in the
month around 100 guests attended a small
leaving ceremony including former
colleagues from other studios addressing
this event the Konami spokesperson said
we're not sure what kind of thing this
was Simon Parkin writer of the original
New Yorker piece confirming Kojima's
departure has since released an image of
this farewell gathering it's believed
Kojima has a non-compete clause that
expires in December which correlates to
previous reports although the specifics
of the arrangement aren't clear this
means Kajima will not be able to enter
into new partnerships until after this
period in March gamespot first reported
that kojima was set to leave the company
sources revealed that the japanese auto
would part ways with konami following
the completion of metal gear solid 5 the
phantom pain which was released on sep
tember the first in july the japanese
voice actor for Metal Gear Solid Snake
stated that Kojima Productions no longer
as a development studio this followed
the cancellation of silent Hills and the
removal of Kojima's name from the
Phantom Pain's box art so what do you
think's going on have you been doing any
investigative research of your own let
us know in the comments I'm Kate you can
follow me on twitter at how not to draw
and thanks for watching